the 239th program of this is your world
takes you to the product law district in
northern Laos which has a deep
connection with a war in Vietnam
the 1962 Geneva agreement set up terms
under which the coalition government
would rule Lowe's with the extreme right
headed by Prince Silvana Puma and the
left the product law led by Prince
Supanova the United States began bombing
areas in northern Laos about a year and
a half ago on the ground that the North
Vietnamese were bringing supplies over
the so-called Ho Chi Minh Trail through
Laos and into South Vietnam strategic
bombings by b-52s since lost note
December raises the question of whether
the war in Vietnam will spread to Laos a
Japanese news gathering team visits sam
neua near the North Vietnamese border
a village of 3000 sam neua is in the
center of the part of lao controlled
areas the village was abandoned when the
bombing began
now from time to time some of the people
return
stores open only from 4:00 to 7:00 in
the morning to avoid air attacks
people appear to be calm but the
soldiers carrying guns symbolize the
agony of war in this area about the size
of Honshu Laos has a population of only
two and a half million quiet unwarlike
people they are Buddhists in many
temples are scattered throughout the
area older priests have left the region
under bombing and only the young monks
remain
the local people say that all of the
product laws districts have been bombed
the United States bombing concentrates
on the roads villages factories a part
of law consulate-general was established
in fung sully the 250 kilometers
northwest of sam neua people left the
towns and villages when the bombing
began about a year and a half ago they
went into the mountains and jungles to
begin a new life they say they can
easily avoid the attacks by living in
the mountains
they have started whole new villages
like this one near sam neua since the
men have volunteered for either army
service or work in the factories only
women children and the older people are
left behind in the villages the women
are pounding rice and weaving they have
a fairly comfortable life better than
during the French colonial period there
are sufficient food in the potted loud
districts and the people provide for
most of their own daily needs
military training is a recognized part
of their daily lives
the lowchen militia like the vietnamese
is a part of the People's Liberation
Army it is established in various
districts the people make Spears before
leaving for training they listen
intently to the group leader who
explains that rightist influences
gathering in the government in vientiane
neutralist like savanna puma for bid for
an intervention in trying to follow the
1962 Geneva agreement they have refused
United States intervention in order to
avoid being drawn into the Vietnamese
War but the rightest welcomed
intervention by the United States in
view of this conflict the product law
could bring about a change of power in
the NCR
despite the tense political situation
life in the mountain villages continuous
peacefully
it is a wedding day for a couple in the
village young girls are busy preparing
for the feast there is plenty of food
one man prepares a pig
the bride and groom walked toward their
new home and the ceremony begins
wedding guests leave money and gifts on
the table setup for the occasion
lotions place food in the hands of the
bride and groom
they have another interesting custom
tying their hands together with black
cotton string lotions believed that the
more strings they use the greater will
be the happiness of the newlyweds
outside they have been preparing a drink
and now everyone joins
dancing follows the wedding ceremony
everyone dances the lam thon which
originated in Thailand but has become
popular involves
the caves built into the limestone of
the mountains near sam neua are the
center of most village activities
here the people are safe from the
bombing
though the caves are cold and damp the
Village People furnish them and make
them as comfortable as they can there
are underground classrooms during the
period of the French colonialists 98% of
the people were illiterate in all of
laws there were only 300 teachers in
1945 now there are 400 teachers in the
potted loud district alone and the
number of children attending school has
increased by threefold in the last 10
years
this is the auto repair shop in sam neua
here young mechanics learn how to make
repairs in the potted logs district they
follow the Chinese slogan of working out
through your own efforts the idea is to
develop self-reliance people in the
potted loud districts also make their
own textiles even their own medicines
about 50 men work at this shop they
repaired 113 cars from January through
September last year
this is a rest period the men are
smoking pipes made of bamboo stems
there is also a blacksmith shop in this
cave where 30 employees with six and a
half hours a day there are three
furnaces in which the men melt down
pieces of bombs dropped in nearby areas
they make tools hatchets knives and
agricultural implements
bust here the product law built this
weaving plant for girls 17 to 19 work in
lamplight power is furnished by foot
pedals the girls make military uniforms
skirts and scars
the girl employees say they are not
afraid of the enemy they will willingly
endure any hardship no matter how long
the fight goes on there will be no
happiness for anyone until the United
States is defeated
there are also printing shops and a
radio broadcasting station in these
stages
this is a French shop where the law cuts
up the central party organ of the Liao's
Patriotic Front is published about 50
people are employed in this shop which
spreads into many adjoining air caves
divided into mess hall press room
conference room and so forth
also located in the cave this is the
only broadcasting station in the potted
LA district it broadcasts a 30-minute
programs a day mostly News one half-hour
program consists of music most of the
news programs are in lotion but the
foreign broadcasts are made in French
near Samuel oh the lotion People's
Liberation Army has established a
military school called the comma Dom
military school in honor of a hero of
the war against the French the school
was founded 15 years ago during the
resistance war when the People's
Liberation Army fought against it the
NCN government in the savannakhet and
kama Wan provinces of southern Laos and
had control of some areas it was a day
before graduation and the students were
in their final phases of training they
learn the duties of the soldiers of
lotion People's Liberation Army to
destroy the enemy to mobilize the people
to participate in production
graduation was held in one of the larger
caves
come to see pond dawn the supreme
commander of the ocean People's Army
spoke to the graduates
the battle will be long and difficult he
said all graduates must at all times
show a Nero ik spirit of self-sacrifice
to do everything they can to overcome
the enemy and expand the liberated areas
the graduating class cheers their leader
prince sutanu von the head of the
Lausanne Patriotic Front or pilot love
is 57 years old he is a half-brother of
prince2 vana Puma when the supernova
returned to Laos in 1941 after several
years education in France he worse than
a road construction project during this
period he became aware of the four
living conditions of the people and
decided in 1945 to work toward
independence when the aleutian Patriotic
Front was formed in 1956 he was selected
as chairman
interviewed he stated the tension and
confusion in Laos are the odd growth of
a conspiracy by the United States and
Savannah Puma and the rightest
government in vientiane to trample the
Geneva agreement of 1956 for a year and
a half
United States bombers have been hitting
Laos moreover the United States uses
lotion in South Vietnamese agents to
bring the southern and central parts of
Laos under its control and to link South
Vietnam with Thailand he doesn't
consider this a problem because the
United States can be forced to pull out
these states that the present lotion
government has the mark of a People's
coalition government but is actually a
puppet of the United States which uses
Savannah Puma to carry out aggressive
plans that is why the people are
determined to resist such scheming and
deception
although a recognized leader of the
Lausanne Patriotic Front supernova is a
friendly man who even takes time out of
his busy day to take physical training
and keep in close touch with the younger
people of the movement this has been a
translation of the Japanese commentary
on a visit to the potted Lao areas
you